CANNOT BELIEVE HER EYES.
HERE'S JEANNE MOOS.
>> Reporter: KIDS AND GLASSES
ARE CUTE.
BUT ATE NOT OFTEN YOU GET TO
WATCH A BABY SEE HER PARENTS
CLEARLY FOR THE FIRST TIME.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> Reporter: SO THAT'S WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE, 10-MONTH-OLD PIPER
MUST HAVE BEEN THINKING WEARING
HER NEW PINK GLASSES AS SHE WENT
FROM EYEING HER MOM.
TO EYEING HER DAD.
AND NOW MILLIONS ARE EYEING THIS
VIDEO.
TOUCHED, THOUGH MAYBE NOT AS
TOUCHED AS HER DAD, ANDREW
VERDUSCO WAS.
>> IT TOOK ME A LOT TO HOLD A
TEAR IN.
>> Reporter: HER PARENTS GOT
WORRIED WHEN PIPER SEEMED TO BE
HAVING AN ISSUE WITH CRAWLING.
A PEDIATRICIAN SENT THEM TO AN
EYE DOCTOR WHO FOUND PIPER TO BE
EXTREMELY FAR SIGHTED.
EVERYONE WANTS TO KNOW HOW DO
THEY DETERMINE A BABY'S
PRESCRIPTION WHEN A BABY CAN'T
READ AN EYE CHART, CAN'T ANSWER
THAT OFTEN TRICKY QUESTION,
WHICH IS BETTER, THIS OR THIS?
OPTOMETRISTS JOKE ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF TREATING CHILDREN.
>> NOW, ONE OF THE --
>> Reporter: YOU CAN'T JUST TAPE
THEM TO THE INSTRUMENTS.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEM OF COURSE
WITH CHILDREN NOT THE SAME AS
THE ADULT EXAM.
>> BY DILATING A CHILD'S EYES
AND SHINING A LIGHT IN THROUGH
VARIOUS LENSES IT IS POSSIBLE
FOR EYE DOCTORS TO COME UP WITH
A ROUGH PRESCRIPTION.
AN ORGANIZATION OFFERS SUCH
EXAMS FREE TO KIDS UNDER THE AGE
OF 1 NATIONWIDE.
AS FOR PIPER.
>> SHE IS ACTUALLY STARTING TO
CRAWL.
WE SEE A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
>> Reporter: IF ONLY THEY CAN
GET HER TO KEEP HER GLASSES ON.
>> SHE LIKES TO TAKE THE GLASSES
OFF, THE FLOOR IS A DROOM.
GLASSES ARE THE DRUMSTICK.
MOM.
DAD.